ん
[音楽]
me
市は
私は今回社会を変えてみちゃうっていう
テーマで話させてもらうんですけど他のて
とトークと違って結構曖昧なテーマで
は社内にぜひ話すんだろうっていう感じだ
と思うんですけど
まあ結構面白いたもので2最後まで聴いて
ください
私の名前はたけど見るですジャズ大学国際
教養学部の二年でニュースロックっていう
アカウントを通して情報発信をしたり中に
入って農業をしたり仲と農業の差しを作っ
たりしてますん
今回の話は私がなんで田舎に行っているの
か情報発信をしているのか
雑誌を作っているのかということに
つながってくるのでもし良ければ最後まで
来てください
つ前なんですけど私の
気持ちの反証すると
2んをっ
この中になるマークになったと思うすごい
モヤモヤして苦しくてへ来てたんです
私立の高校に通わせてもらったりおいしい
ご飯を食べさせてもらったり
オーストラリアにここに年節減留学に6日
せてもらったけど
でもなんかすごい
苦しくて
物質的には豊かな生活だったけどなんか
ずっと見たされなくて
誰も私の話を聞いてくれない気がしていた
し
いつもなんか一人でチームラリンな気持ち
で生きてたんですよね
それでその気持ちがこの中で家から地元
から出られなくなった時にすごい大きくて
しまって
出されちゃうんじゃないか
最初はそのキー苦しみは私だけのもので私
だけがこんなに苦しいなーって思って
でも苦しすぎて中にとどめておくことが
できなくて
でも棄却する誰が理解してくれるかは
わかんなくて
わかんないなって
j いいやと思ってその不特定多数の舞
遊び版とかで言っちゃおうとって
発信じゃないまあどっちかっていうと
をし始めて
それでやっとワイド友達とかに付いこの人
だから話すっていうよりはまたがただ弾
ダムに自分が思っている自分のモヤモヤを
話し始めて
ねそうしていくと意外とみんな私の話を
ちゃんと聞いてくれるし
話した上でみんなも同じような苦しみを
持ってて
でそれで友達とそういう話をずっとして
いくうちに
icu の足を5分しょんインスタグラム
のアカウントがあって
それは何か
その ic は生徒がみんな匿名で自分の
好きなこと思ってる事っていうのを乗せて
もらえるっていうアカウントだったんです
けどそこになかっ
画質的には豊かなのになんでこんなに
変わったなんだろうって何走行走っている
人がいて
なんかじゃあ私のこのを感じているモヤモ
ヤって
私とかあるか私の周りの人がだけの問題で
なくて
この日本をとってくると大きいかもしれ
ないけど日本の若者みんなの問題なんだ
なって
思って
本当はそのみんなが帰っている問題って
ことは
解決できないからみんなが書いてるわけで
あってすごい大変の問題だということなん
ですけどなんか私は皆がかかっている問題
だって気づいた時にすごいなんか
軽くなってみんな運転なら大丈夫じゃん
だってええじゃあそしたら原因か迷っ
その幻の悩みのその悩むので原因を考えて
みることにしたんですよ
時間をたくさん
どんどん考えていうか自分なんでもあり
ますよね考えていくうちに
こうやってモヤモヤする原因を考えてもう
モヤモヤしてたんだからわからないん
だってことを気づいて
で逆にモヤモヤが増えていくような感じに
なっちゃう
あじゃあちょっと考え方を変えなきゃいけ
あじゃあ
なんでモヤモヤしたとか何で苦しいのか
じゃなくて苦しくなかった時はどの生活を
してたのかを考えろ
私がうれしく5なろうと思って規模ず
苦しかったん
さをどんなときにそれがその高校にれ
セリカオーストラリア留学で
苦しくなかったなぁ
その時何で苦しくなかったんだお考えて
みよっ
今の生活と何が違うのかプラム寿命って
比べて言ったら納期2っちがくて
一つはオーストラリアでの生活は生きて
いる実感
あったですねじゃあ生きている時間だと
もう一つは受け入れてくれる人たち私の居
場所があっ
まずその最初の行ってきている実感がどう
やること何かっていうと
私はそのオーストラリアの中ですっごい中
の方に行ったので
隣の家の人まで車で5分
日本ちょっと考えられないけれど中で
だからその家族た弱のんだとかではなかっ
たけど自分たちが食べるように牛を4度を
買っててその毎年1頭ずつ
屠殺して買い足し食べるということがあっ
たりしたい
あとは私もその解体分
経験させてもらって
あとは数
家の畑
小さい畑で夜ご飯のようによるごはんよう
にねー今日釣ってきたりとかあとポスト
グランドバザーもじいちゃんがすごい
釣りが好きだったから一緒に釣りに行って
蟹とか魚をとってそれを一緒に夕ご飯食べ
たりとかどうやってやるのか自分の命を
生かすために自分を食べるのために自分の
体を使って自分じゃシャツあってい
動くということがすごい
それって日本の生活ではあんまりなくて
日本の数生活だったら
まあ
ごはんを食べるとかお肉を食べるって言っ
たら芸術にされたお肉しか私たちはをの
浮かばないし鶏っていう動物パワステミク
会社のご飯だよと言われてもの私たちには
そこにが回学教してしまうし
その日本生活ではどんどん生きている時間
っていうことがないんだなっていうのを
すごい感じて
もう一つは受け入れてくれること
いうことも大きな違いだなぁと思っ
日本にも友達はいた子だけどなんかその
友達っていうの学校とがバイト先とかで
ので人たちでだからそこには伊豆
私っていう武田3うっていう存在の前に何
橋のラベルが付いので
大学生とか
女の業とか
上智大学のかというラベルが付いてて
私が何かを成し遂げ言って受け入れて
くれる場所ではなかっなんて持ってて
でもそのストラリアでの生活は
役割とないただただ私として皆が変わって
くれてお蕎麦目に立ったりポスター b の
c 席だったり近所の人だったらいいか今
と同じだったり
私が別に何を成し遂げてなくても家が何人
でも受け入れてくれる場所私たちて
受け入れてくるっていう環境があって
それがなんかすごい暖かくてそれが
嬉しかったんだなってことを思い出したん
ですよね
じゃあ最初そんな幸せなん
画像するにはオーストラヘイクしかない
じゃんと思って
また
じゃっかち君でだってオーストラリアその
時国が閉まってたから寿司をとって
4回よく考えてみたらそれは国の話ぶりの
違う星じゃなくて
ちょっととか私が
日本で生きている時間のアン生活を送れて
いなくてたことだ私が日本に居場所が
なかっただけなんだな
一つ作ってやろうと思うのでじゃあでも
その2つってどうしたら成し遂げられるの
かなーって考えたときにやっぱり私ども
ストラーいう生活の大部分を占めてたのは
一番大きなキーワードは田舎と思うよう
だったのでじゃその2つを日本であうって
ぜひ中津農業ってどうしたらいいんだろう
と思ううちに私ああそんなに身近に田舎と
かなかったんじゃないかどう背負って指を
考えてみたら
忠孝が同じの仲いい友達の母さんは新規
就農って正しく農業を始めてた人なんだ
から破邪その人に農家さんの話を聞いて
みようと思って
で友達を紹介して話して話をさせてもらっ
たら
ちょっと話が面白くて
今年がもし角中が入ってこれだ
そのかあさんに紹介してもらってどんどん
近所の農家さんだったり
奈良県の川上村っていうところだったり
新潟のその場所もあってところだったり
いろんなところでのカカオやして言って
そうするともう秒だけじゃなくて漁業と
カリン料とかそういういろんな関わりが
増えてて
で中そうするとそこでんおじいちゃぱちゃ
とか大人の人と話してるとなんかいろんな
自分が元々知ってた知識がそれ実態となっ
て現れてきて
例えばその地球温暖化とか私もちゃんと
地球本何がヤバいってことを知ったけどで
も自分の生活を変えるぐらいにはカエルに
は理解できなかったというか認識できる
ようなんだけど
でもその
漁師のおじちゃんと話してたら
もともとはなんかに良い形で取れていた魚
が今釣れながら特会を取れるとかそういう
話を聞いてほんとにもうどんどんどんどん
月が溜まっちゃってるんだなあっていう
ことを
絶対として知ることができてマーサー地球
温暖化だけじゃなくていろんな話が自分が
戻っと知った知識とつながっていって
私が生きている私は学んでロシア自分の
身体は自分が誰も使っているってことを
近くさせてくれる場面がすごいーっ
それがもうまず一番
はじめに楽しくて
でもそうやってどんどんどんどんいろんな
大人と関わっていくとまたその欲しかった
いい場所っていうものができてきてなんか
私はその自分の話を誰に聞いてくれないっ
ていうことだ何かすごい一番
寿都なかったから田舎ではでいい
みんなおじいちゃんおばあちゃんとかは別
に私がないようなしたげてよおと関係なく
ただ
私としてみうちゃんとして受け入れて率直
に話を聞いてまっすぐ向き合って話して
くれて
嬉しいと思って
私はされてなんか自分の話を聞いてくれる
人が増えて行くたびに自分の居場所が増え
ていきましてな帰れる場所
増えていく根拠ないそこが増えて御用聞き
ねそうするとなんかなんだかわかんない
モヤモヤにさいなまれることもどうぞすく
なっ
そうやってなんか否かで
いろんな指摘の関わりを増やしていくと
なんか
より戻ると東京でもツボいろんな素敵なお
隣であってみんな私は大学生ですじゃなく
てただけだみゆして受け入れてくれると
いう話てくれる一人であるようなので
なんか
西講座で友達ほとんどんもともと仲良い
友達みたけどトンどんどん自分の想いを
簡単に話せる友達増えてって
著者でなんておっしゃ道の駅づらさが
なくなってきて
お皿ない中との行は市にとっては最後で
残ってこうやって話してしまうと私は違い
なかった農業みんなに勧めたいっ
結論になっちゃうじゃないけど
そういうわけじゃなくてなんか
な
一番一体のワースの苦しさがあるときに
それは当たり前だと思って自分自身を
変えるとてもいいんじゃないか
なんか
苦しいこととか難しいこととかがあるとき
とかうまくいかないことがあると気になっ
その
スタンダードに見合うようにするのが
当たり前の社会になっていると思うんです
けど
でもそれをし続けていると自分が好きな
ものとか自分がやりたいこととかもうあの
自分自身の
なっちゃうと思うんですよねだから
いうと生きてる実感がなかった
死んでも変わんないじゃないんだな
表示になっちゃう
だけど
ませんそれこそそれをしすぎて自分が自分
自身が好きなものない人でつまらないで
いいんだと思う
その
洋服とか漫画とか音楽とかすごい深い知識
とか思ってこれが好きなんだよねて語っ
てる友達帯びて
ばいいなぁなんで私はこんなに浅はかなん
だろう
てくださいなので思ってたけどで魅力
ようこそやって田舎とかまあ今では東京で
もないけどずいろんな素敵な人たちと
関わって対等に話してもらって私の話で
っていうところ通じてなんか自分は
自分の好きなものがあったんだって
思い出してそれこそ私は小学2年生の部人
が算数の時間に
青い鳥文庫を読んじゃないですか足でそれ
ぐらいはちゃ本は好きだったしそれを忘れ
てたし
ですから私たちは本当ん
自分の好きなものがあって
やりたいことがあって自分があるのに
それを外に合わせることで見えなくなっ
ちゃってるだけなんじゃない
がとうございまーそのフル強いですって
言うと苦しいことからに出る好きなことし
ていいよって言ってくれる大人とかって
入れたんですけどでも
その好きなことがわからないんだよなっ
ちゃうと思うおっしゃそうだでもでも
よーく考え
でもそのん
外に合わせた好きな他の人と比べたときに
私は好きじゃないとか
あと世間から見たらこの日織辺だからとか
そういう事を考えないでただ自分の中で
どれが何が好きなのかということを考え
たら
絶対みんな何が好きなものがあると思うん
ですねそれがまあチョコレートないせいか
もしれないしを張ってあったでしょうかも
しれない沈むって本当に何でもいいと思う
し
がそのん
自分が好きなものを好きでいられるように
身の回りの社会とか世界を変えちゃって
いいだと思う
[音楽]
ん
そうやってなんか世界を変えてみるって
言うと大きくて無理だろ話に聞こえると
思うんですけどうん大きいんですけどそれ
が買えると聞いけどでも絶対私たちできる
ことが仕事に日常的にやっちゃってること
だとじゃないだって私中生きてるだけで誰
かとかガーって誰かに影響はたいってで
そうないかまた違う何か影響はないってで
私たち
人が社会で私食堂がまあ世界の一員だから
私たちが何か行動するということは絶対に
何か何か変えているセガ変えてるって言う
事だから
まあもともととして女性が帰っちゃってる
し
それはもっと良い方に使っちゃってもいい
のかなって
から自分が行きやすいように自分が好きな
ことをできるように自分が好きなものを
好きだと思えるような人と一緒にいて
自分
を好きでいて
っていうことで良い方向に自分の世界から
もと世界全体を張って言っちゃって
いいんじゃないかなと帰っていけるんじゃ
ないかなって持ってい
まあ
それで打ったら私は
自分が楽になりたかったから農業片田舎を
引退してそしたら友達もみんななんか
はじめ農業をしたい場でな書きたいんだ
けど慣れてきてあじゅ竣工リップ一緒にし
てって友達
ほとんど農協とか言いながらいるうちにあ
じゃあこれぞ私にした方が面白いじゃんっ
てなって
そしたらまたそれを不特定多数んですか
よってくれて
でまたこうやって出品しすべき
でも出版する21を聞いてまあ
その誰かあなた一人あなたがいい自分も
よくやってみようかなとか搬送れなくても
下じゃ好きなことをやるために来てみよう
かなとか
思ったら私は元世界を変えちゃってるし
っていう風に工夫に何か簡単に世界って
られちゃうんじゃないかなってん
思っています
農業じゃなくてもいいし中じゃなくても
いいからみんなが行きやすい場所
ただしたい人話せる人を見つけられて
もやもやがなく生きていけたらいいなと
思っ
最後の話を聞いてくれてありがとうござい
ました